bien este vídeo lo vamos a dedicar a las
propiedades de los exponentes en
cocientes pues vamos a empezar con este
ejemplo que dice que 5 a la sexta
potencia 5 a la 6 dividido entre 5 a la
2 5 al cuadrado vamos a ver otra vez que
es 5 a la 6 bueno un número elevado a
una potencia a un exponente es ese
número multiplicado el número de veces
que dice la potencia entonces esto es 5
por 5 por 5 x
5 x 5 x 5 o sea esto es el número 5
multiplicado 6 veces y esto está siendo
dividido por 5 al cuadrado o 5 a la
segunda potencia que entonces es 5 por 5
pero ya conocemos
ya conocemos este ya conocemos que
cuando algo está siendo multiplicado y
dividido por el mismo número entonces se
pueden cancelar entonces digamos este 5
que está aquí cancela este que está acá
y este cancela a este y entonces que es
lo que me queda pues me queda el 5 que
se está multiplicando por sí mismo uno
dos tres cuatro veces o sea que esto es
igual a 5 a la 4
esto es 5 a la cuarta potencia a la 4 de
acuerdo y observamos que obtenemos lo
mismo que si hubiéramos restado los
exponentes osea que si al exponente del
numerador le restamos el exponente del
denominador 6 menos dos es cuatro y es
el mismo resultado que obtuvimos de
acuerdo esto es igual a 5 a las 6 menos
2 o sea el exponente del numerador menos
el exponente del denominador ahora vamos
a ver este otro ejemplo a ver me
gustaría tratar de hacerlo con algunos
colores para para a ver si queda más
claro entonces el ejemplo que yo tengo
es el 5 a la sexta potencia sí que está
multiplicando
5 alam
déjame ver al cuadrado claro entonces 5
al cuadrado vamos a utilizar este otro
color y entonces habíamos dicho que para
el caso de la multiplicación es
simplemente los exponentes se van a
sumar osea que esto va a ser igual a 5 a
la sexta
más vamos aquí haciendo todo el juego de
colores para que quede más claro no 5 a
la sexta más 2 5 a la 6 más 2 y de la
misma manera
vamos a
aquí escribir qué es lo que pasa lo que
acabamos de ver cuando hay cocientes
entonces de esta manera podemos decir
que cuando yo tengo es cinco alas
sexta que está siendo dividido por cinco
al cuadrado
esto lo voy a poder poner como en 5
a la 6
menos
y entonces esto es lo que hemos estado
viendo hasta este momento
bueno pues veamos este ejercicio que es
el que dice que si tengo
6 al 7 dividido entre 6 a 3 pues como ya
hemos estado viendo pues esto es seis a
las siete menos tres que es igual a seis
a la cuarta potencia seis a la cuatro
a ver voy a mover esto para hacer este
otros ejercicios a ver vamos a mover
esto para hacer otros ejercicios ya
estoy ahí listo bueno pues vamos a hacer
este el siguiente ejemplo es este que
que tengo aquí entonces qué pasa si yo
tengo tres a la cuarta potencia 3 a la 4
dividido entre 3 a la 10 bueno entonces
utilizando las propiedades básicas que
ya conocemos entonces 3 a la 4 es lo
mismo que tener tres por tres por tres
por tres o sea el 3 siendo multiplicado
cuatro veces por sí mismo y entonces 3 a
la 10 pues quién es entonces es 3
por 3 x 3 por 3 o sea voy a tener que
ponerlo 10 veces por 3 x
cuántos llevo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 muy bien ya tengo tres a la 10 no
lo que quiere decir y entonces
utilizando las propiedades que ya
conocemos este 3 con este 13 cancela el
segundo cancela con este este se cancela
con este y este se cancela con este y
entonces qué es lo que obtengo bueno
pues entonces lo que yo obtengo ahora es
que esto va a ser igual a 1 sobre me
queda el 3 siendo multiplicado 1 2 3 4 5
6 3 veces digo perdón el 3 multiplicado
esto es 3 a la sexta esto es lo que
obtuvimos y ahora vamos a hacerlo con
las propiedades que ya estábamos
revisando las propiedades de los
exponentes que hemos estado revisando en
estos vídeos y entonces esto sería lo
mismo otra manera de trabajar lo sería
y ya sabemos y aplicando la propiedad de
los números exponentes que se están
dividiendo siempre que tengan la misma
base
puedo restar los exponentes entonces
esto va a ser igual a 3 a la 4 menos 10
entonces me queda 3 a la 4 menos 10 es
menos 6 yo sorpresa acabamos de aprender
algo nuevo
resulta que 3 a la menos 6 es
exactamente lo mismo que uno sobre 3 a
las 6 o sea que estamos aprendiendo una
nueva a trabajar con exponentes
negativos y acabamos de establecer está
esta relación que me dice que 3 a la
menos 6 es igual a 1 sobre 3 a las 6 o
sea que en general lo que estamos
encontrando y estamos definiendo esta
relación en este momento es que
a la menos ve es igual a 1 sobre a al
ave y esto es pues muy importante y es
un muy buen resultado el que acabamos de
aprender ahora
ahora quiero enumerar la otra propiedad
que hemos estado utilizando para
construir todo esto que está aquí que es
la que habíamos mencionado en el vídeo
previo y que estamos utilizando pero
nada más por recordar la que me dice que
a a la b dividido entre a a la c es
igual a a a la b - bueno esta es la
propiedad que estábamos éste
que hemos estado utilizando ahora ya con
esto que aprendimos en me gustaría que
pasáramos a hacer ejercicios mucho más
complicados más elaborados para poner en
práctica todas estas herramientas que
estamos aprendiendo entonces a ver vamos
a continuar
listo ya tenemos más espacio para seguir
trabajando
ahora vamos a hacer este ejercicio que
es más elaborado como ya habíamos dicho
y entonces este ejercicio más o menos
nos dice lo siguiente nos dice qué tal
si tengo a la tercer potencia que
multiplica a b
que multiplica también que éste está a
la cuarta todo esto va a estar dividido
entre a al cuadrado que está haciendo x
en vez
de acuerdo y todo esto no tengo elevado
a la tercer potencia de acuerdo y para
hacer una distinción de haber esta
potencia le va a poner de otro color no
esté ésta es la 3 de acuerdo entonces
vamos a empezar simplificando lo que
está en el interior utilizando todas las
herramientas que hemos estado trabajando
de acuerdo entonces y simplificando lo
que está en el interior y también voy a
tratar de utilizar algunos colores para
asociar que se vea que los elementos que
estoy asociando cuáles son entonces por
ejemplo y vamos a empezar a la 3
dividido entre a la 2 ya habíamos dicho
que se restan los este los exponentes
que me quedaría a la 1 que es a nada más
o lo puedo ver como si se estuviera
multiplicando a por ahora dividido entre
ahora pues entonces dos se van a
cancelar y me va a quedar simplemente
a la 1 de acuerdo entonces está a que
estoy poniendo aquí es la misma que está
acá y es la misma que está acá de
acuerdo para que vayamos esté
identificando todas las en todos los
elementos ahora vamos con la vid
entonces ve a la cuarta dividido entre b
lo puedes ver otra vez como si estuviera
multiplicando cuatro veces y se va a
cancelar uno y me va a quedar ve a las
tres b a la 3 b al cubo o también
diciendo que cuatro menos uno es
3 el exponente es 3 entonces te va a
quedar ve a la 3 y todo esto está siendo
elevado a la tercer potencia no es ahora
lo que lo que dice nuestro ejercicio y
entonces ahora continuemos con nuestro
ejercicio y entonces éste va a ser vamos
a ver vamos a respetar nuestros colores
este va a ser
a la 3 si simplemente este el exponente
se aplica a la a y del otro lado me va a
quedar pues
a la tercera potencia y todo esto está
elevado a la tercera potencia también de
acuerdo y finalmente entonces este me va
a quedar
va a ser igual voy a poner aquí abajo
esto va a ser igual a al cubo y por la
propiedad que hemos estado viendo con
los exponentes se van a multiplicar y
entonces me va a quedar ve a la 3 a la
33 por 39 esto me queda ve a la novena
potencia y con eso ya terminamos este
este ejercicio ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio me dice lo siguiente qué tal
si tengo 25
x
a la sexta
y todo esto está dividido por 20 por 20
y sí
a la quinta x cuadrada
la quinta x4 de acuerdo
entonces me voy a reescribir los voy a
reescribir esto voy a reorganizar los
términos y reescribir los de una manera
que es válida y te vas a dar cuenta esto
va a ser a 20 igual a 25 sobre 20 que
multiplica voy a poner las cosas juntas
a los números los pongo juntos las x las
va a poner juntas entonces clases x
entre x al cuadrado y luego las de las
pongo juntos también ahí se están
multiplicando y me queda ya a la 6
dividido entre las 5 esta norma lo estoy
haciendo para que sea más claro más
fácil trabajar este con las cosas que
estoy haciendo entonces vamos a
simplificar esto que tenemos aquí y
entonces el 25 sobre 20 simplemente
puedo observar que ambos números son
divisibles entre 5 cosas esto de que
está aquí se va a convertir en cinco
cuartos
y luego el que está aquí es tengo x al 1
esté entre x al cuadrado dijimos que se
restan los exponentes esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tener a ver lo
voy a poner hasta acá para que se vea
claro es x a la menos 1 pero también es
igual a 1 sobre x de acuerdo entonces
aquí va a tener múltiple prefiero
ponerlo como 1 sobre x y este que está
acá este otro término que está acá llega
a las 6 entre ya las 5
se restan los exponentes 65 me queda
simplemente a la 1 por jay y entonces
ahora
reescribiendo todas las reagrupando todo
lo que tengo esto me va a quedar igual a
/ 4x y bueno finalmente logramos hacer
nuestro ejercicio que es un poco más
elaborado este a mí me gustaría
invitarte a que practiques
y bueno pues este nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo